Hey everyone,
welcome to the Gridiron Heights Christmas party!
Keep in mind layoffs are coming.
Oh no.
I’m freaking out.
No. No. No.
I’m not being replaced.
I’m still hurt.
See!
OW!
Santa Gruden,
I’m giving all my players away, OK?
And an Amari for you.
WOAH, A RECEIVER!
I’ve never had one before.
Hey, who wants a Derek Carr?!
Hey, how about you, Dan Snyder, man?
He’s only $125 million?!
Oh, can I, Jerry?
Please?!
OK, Odell, this is a work event.
Behave yourself.
WOOO!
I HAVE STRONG OPINIONS ABOUT ALL OF YOU!
That’s a fine-
HEY, WOAH WOAH ZEKE, I’LL FINE YOU TOO-
THANK YOU.
I just came to get my stuff.
You’re having a party without me?
I’m having the time of my life.
I’m back!
Gronk may be too old for this.
OK, the NFC's a mess.
YEAH IT IS.
Where’s Eli?
Oh, he’s babysitting.
PEW! PEW!
LET’S PRETEND PLAYOFFS!
NO!
I’M GOING FOR REAL!
IF YOU GUYS DON’T GO TO BED,
SANTA WON’T COME.
I’M TALL, BUT I CAN RUN.
WHY ARE THESE KIDS SO MOBILE?!